good evening I'm Mary ham and welcome to
ma'am review that's right everyone I've
taken over meme review haha
meme review YouTube's favorite show
everyone let's just jump into it Keanu
Reaves admit that he's a lonely guy and
says I don't have anyone in my life get
this man a friend I don't care what it
takes
someone befriend Keanu Reeves goddammit
get this man some push right now my man
Keanu Reeves will not suffer
he lost his puppy goddammit is that not
enough now since I marry him the first
male host on meme review this episode is
dedicated to my guys my dudes my dudes
only if you're a girl or anything else
leave this is me and the boys watching
spoons in the microwave
sparkling we've all been there and this
could be you and me Keanu think about it
me and the boys in creative mode now
this is an older meme but it has
returned in the theme of spider-man
me and the boys in any game with
customizable characters this photo this
goddamn photo of the villains in
spider-man cartoon has gone viral
me and the boys pretending that lollipop
sticks are cigarettes oh wow that's
totally relatable
me and the boys at our boy funeral this
is so sad me and the boys waiting for
the pizza rolls to be done everyone
knows that moment when you and the boys
are waiting for the pizza rolls to be
done do you want me to say that mean one
more time Mia the boys or the boys and I
me and the boys when we get an invite to
a girl's sleepover and pretending to be
gay for ten years heck yeah
me and the boys off to fight spider-man
again ah Sh here we go again
me and the boys rearranging the
encyclopedias in the school library
me and the boys when we all choose the
same character in Smash went me and the
boys when one of the boys get a
girlfriend it's so sad
me and the boys switching names when we
have a substitute teacher these are so
bad why are these God ever hit when
you're enemies all grouped together and
become a really popular meme I'm by the
side of the village
just me and boys when mom mops the floor
just me and the boys discussing the
gross domestic product per capita of
Honduras we've all been there smashed
like if you can relate me and the boys
throughout the years this is so sane
it's time to go was IA good mean yes you
were actually the best meme of 2019 so
far debatable but let's take a group
photo
me and the boys taking a crew photo with
death himself this is so wholesome
there's nothing like me and the boys
there's nothing like me and their boys
when the teacher is picking two teams
for PE there's nothing like me and the
boys robbing an ATM in Avengers capacity
there's just nothing like it
me and the boys encapsulate just the
best feeling of being you with a boys
and whamon you will never understand you
weren't even supposed to be here and I
tell you to leave go this is boys
special boys special episode no women
alright this one is for the girls
me and the boys breaking that kiss see I
bet you wish you leave now didn't you me
and the boy meme gets in me and the boy
me and a moment boy meme gets the
goddamn eight point five point twenty
next meme that actually hurts we are
sticking with the theme of boy memes
okay I'll marry him the first and I
shall decide the next me there's another
older me that has now gotten a new
little face makeover okay it's well boys
we did it boys we did it racism is no
more thanks to the Penguins in
Madagascar but they won't just stop
there okay
major companies when they ban plastic
straws well boys we did it pollution is
no more Apple after adding skin colors
to emojis well boys we did it
is no more schools when they hang up
anti-bullying posters bullying is no
more all these issues social issues are
gone
Dhin Dhin Dhin Dhin didn't did the boys
did it Marvel producers when they put
the old female superhero seed into
endgame boys we did it sexism is no more
and you wouldn't even care about that
did I not tell you to leave why don't
formless people just buy a house well
boys we did it homeless people no more
we're doing all these things changing
the world changing the planet
Thank You Madagascar penguin thank you
well boys we did it
gun violence is gone terrorism there's
no more well boys we did it poverty is
no more you're welcome ladies the boys
did it yet again the boys we did it mean
get set
brofist
boy
next meet this episode you thought we
couldn't do three boy themed memes in a
row its boy we okay and we're
celebrating goddamnit
we don't want you here we don't want
your kind here I marry him and I'm
telling you go I'm the guy to hold from
humans and can't stop me
begone thought you're more powerful than
I thought one more meme for the boys one
more mean for the boys that's right
the boy seemed locker room mean
[Music]
the girls were remaining on this video
this is you oh it's so boring oh my god
Becky are you wearing a thong this is us
in the locker room
[Music]
breaking it down
watching Bora for the 500-pound
girls locker room boys locker room
performing toll rituals and [ __ ] now
this meme actually has Russian origin
which gives it an extra plus Lucas I
don't know what it's saying but it is a
shirtless Steve and I if that doesn't
give me respect for a whole nation and I
don't know what goddam will no one
apparently the boys locker girls locker
room PE is the worst oh my god boys
locker room James please stop I told you
I'm not gay
where's this 13th of May oh this is
goddamn meme Jesus Christ dude girls
when someone cheats in dodgeball uh
whatever boys when someone cheats in
dodgeball we at least care about rules
women would never understand girls
insane class boys enjoy dance class
that's right we sacrifice babies girls
sleepover poison sleepovers that's right
we are making rituals in the middle of
the Atlantic oceans in an iceberg that
froze and we manage to make a fire
anyway checkmate females you got nothing
girls locker room
Oh boys locker room
[Applause]
girls in detention boys in detention
[Music]
this is us in detention never done that
have you [ __ ]
girls locker room boys locker room
oh yeah we out here crying we out here
building synchronizing
when theater says get out of class girls
reaction voice reaction boys reaction
coming late to class and standing
outside police reaction when teacher
says get out of clients girls reaction
voice reaction with teachers let's get
out of class girls reaction boys
reaction boys reaction
[Applause]
[Music]
the media classified this video as
sexist because I excluded their hand
entire gender what you never played
super simulator you know it's fun right
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
give it a try and then you can tell me
if it's good or not not convinced yet
okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]